this is now a health emergency of not
its but when officials warned there
would be more UK cases of couvade 19
this afternoon three new patients were
confirmed but it's still the 20th case
diagnosed on Friday that is most
significant the patient who came to this
clinic in Surrey wasn't infected
overseas but here in the UK opening a
new chain of transmission
that's uncomfortably close to home it is
scary I work in London so you see out
there there's more and more people
wearing masks and people talking about
it so you know you don't don't really
think it's gonna happen quite so close
to home until it does the children go to
school they're trained my husband goes
out to landed on a train I work in a
school so the opportunity for you
catching it is pretty high I don't know
what the privacy rules are surrounding
the guy but he should probably as it be
named I don't know whether he's been
named but it would be nice to know
whether you know he's been in contact
with anyone in the town in all UK cases
authorities have had to examine who the
infected person may have passed the
virus onto but this is the first time
they've had to look in the UK for where
the virus came from he may well have
been in contact with somebody who had
beat who had traveled to one of the
infected areas Italy Korea China and
they may not have had symptoms and and
or they may be about to get symptoms
because this is a disease that has an
incubation period during which your
infectious and then you can pass it on
new emergency measures are now likely
the government is looking at giving
schools councils and other parts of the
public sector powers to suspend laws
including health and safety measures to
cope with a pandemic
schools and nurseries will be allowed to
have larger classes to deal with staff
absences the emergency legislation is
expected to be published next week you
would expect us as a responsible
government to be planning for all
eventualities we are planning and we are
working to achieve the best outcome
which is that containment continues to
work as it is working as far as we can
see at the moment but you plan for the
worst as well
so that you ensure that every
eventualities is covered governments
across the world of bolstering their
responses numbers of cases rise the US
announced its first death from the
disease of a woman in her 50s and it
increased travel restrictions from Iran
she was a wonderful woman a medically
high-risk patient in her late 50s four
others are very ill thankfully 15 are
either recovered fully or they're well
on their way to recovery France has
banned gatherings of over 5,000 people
Italy has shut schools and affected
regions for a second week and Japan has
urged all schools remain closed until
the end of March hear the Prime Minister
spoke with top health officials to
examine the UK response ahead of an
emergency cabinet meeting on Monday
Caterina verticies Sky News